so there are seven popular cereals that  no longer qualify as healthy based on  the fda's new definition and once I give  you the list I think most of you will  say who thought those were healthy to  begin with the seven cereals are Raisin  Bran Honey Nut Cheerios Corn Flakes  Honey Bunches of Oats Frosted Mini  Wheats life and Special K by and large  the reason that these don't qualify is  healthy anymore is they have an insane  amount of added sugar in the case of two  of them corn flakes in Special K it's  not so much the added sugar but it's the  sugar plus a whole bunch of sodium I  know that a lot of people are just busy  living their lives and they don't  closely follow some of these nutrition  things but  when it comes to cereal at this point it  should be widely known you look at how  much sugar are they pumping into this  thing and if it's more than a couple of  grams you probably don't want it